Петро Порошенко заявив, що бюджет на 2020 рік
скасовує низку важливих для України реформ.
Експрезидент навів 9 реформ, які, мовляв,
почала впроваджувати його команда.
- На це в них грошей нема.
Сільська медицина
Програми підтримки сільської медицини
справді немає в бюджеті на 2020 рік.
Розрахована вона була на 2018-2020 роки.
Ішлося про президентську державну
цільову програму з побудови нових сільських
амбулаторій, закупівлі телемедобладнання
та транспорту для сільських лікарів.
Центр протидії корупції назвав її
"передвиборною реформою Порошенка", який
навесні перед виборами охоче їздив відкривати
нові медпункти. За даними Рахункової палати, досі
з запланованих майже 600 амбулаторій
побудували лише 17%
і лише 10% готові до експлуатації.
Виділені раніше й не вичерпані досі кошти
лишаються на рахунках, тож їх можна буде
використати наступного року, зокрема,
щоб добудувати розпочаті об'єкти.
Зарплати військовим
У 2020-му грошові виплати
для військовослужбовців ЗСУ залишаться
практично без змін. Новий бюджет скопіював
рівень зарплат в армії після цьогорічного підвищення на 30%.
Водночас передбачене збільшення зарплати
в інших силових структурах:
на 10% в Нацполіції та Нацгвардії,
на 15% - прокордонникам, на 14% - "еменесникам"
та на 6% - міграційній службі,
адже після кількох етапів підняття зарплат у ЗСУ
військовослужбовці інших формувань залишилися далеко позаду.
Виплати багатодітним сім'ям
Щомісячні доплати від держави на третю, четверту,
п'яту й кожну наступну дитину до 6-річного віку
в розмірі прожиткового мінімуму залишаються.
Різниця лише в тому, що досі вони надходили
з місцевих бюджетів за рахунок субвенцій,
а 2020-го року виділятимуться напряму з бюджету.
13-та пенсія
Тринадцятої пенсії в новому бюджеті справді немає.
Запровадили її навесні 2019-го саме
перед президентськими  виборами для пенсіонерів
із повним стажем, але найнижчими пенсіями -
до 1669 гривень.
У березні та квітні вони отримали
дві одноразові доплати по 2400 гривень.
Тоді ж, ще до виборів, Порошенко пообіцяв
зробити цю виплату постійною у вигляді
"13-ої пенсії" наприкінці року.
Менше субсидій
Бюджет на 2020-й рік справді скорочує
обсяг житлових субсидій: із 55 до 47 млрд гривень.
Уряд пояснює це індексацією пенсій і збільшенням
мінімальної зарплати і прожиткового мінімуму,
через що сума субсидії стане меншою. Натомість
експерти вказують на жорсткіші правила
отримання субсидій, які, щоправда,
почали діяти ще 2018-го.
Освітні програми
На освіту у 2020-му році планується направити
145 мільярдів гривень. Це майже на 13% більше,
ніж у бюджеті 2019-го. Проте у співвідношенні
до ВВП грошей справді менше.
Фінансування скоротилося з 6,2% ВВП у 2019-му
до 5,6% у 2020-му. Як і раніше, гроші підуть
на "Нову українську школу",
додаткові виплати вчителям, інклюзивність тощо.
Регіональний розвиток
Що Петро Порошенко мав на увазі, невідомо.
DW не отримала відповіді на свій запит.
Концепції регіонального розвитку за стандартами ЄС не існує.
В Євросоюзі сповідують принцип вирівнювання
розвитку регіонів, проте Україна його не переймала,
а кожна з країн ЄС має свою власну політику
регіонального розвитку, і вони дуже відрізняються одна від одної.
Децентралізація
Тут також не до кінця зрозуміло, що саме
мав на увазі Петро Порошенко.
Бюджет на 2020 рік справді свідчить, що
децентралізація не є пріоритетом нової влади.
Водночас, за словами експертів, якщо
згортання реформи і відбувається, то почалось воно
не за Зеленського, адже необхідні закони
не ухвалюються вже три роки, а грошей
на допомогу новоствореним громадам
виділяється дедалі менше.
Фінансування ЗСУ
Це справді так: 2,57% ВВП на фінансування армії.
Втім, за даними Defense Express, 2019-го року
ці витрати становили  практично стільки ж:
2,58% від розміру ВВП. Водночас оборона та безпека
- один із небагатьох напрямків, видатки по якому
в бюджеті на 2020 рік не скоротили, а збільшили.
На загальне переконання експертів,
бюджет на 2020 рік був скопійований
із попереднього бюджету, тож якщо обидва закони
і згортають якісь реформи, то абсолютно рівною мірою.
Частина тверджень Петра Порошенка
є явним перебільшенням або маніпуляцією.
Програма сільської медицини чи 13-та пенсія не є реформами.
Зауваження щодо зменшення субсидій
формально правильне, проте не свідчить
про згортання реформ. Пріоритетами бюджету
на 2020 стали обслуговування державного боргу,
фінансування правоохоронців,
підвищення обороноздатності держави
та будівництво доріг.
Бюджет піддається критиці, проте не свідчить
ані про згортання реформ, ані про те, що нова влада
скорочуватиме військові витрати
на тлі бажання врегулювати конфлікт на Донбасі.